Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors for another episode of Connors Clinic.
Live, we have a special guest today. It's Beda, a cancer clinic. This is a little bit different
for us. We're so excited to have Caitlin Vasco in here today. She is a home birth mother and she is
has the podcast, the Happy Home Birth podcast. I was introduced to her by my daughter who has been
following her podcast and, oh my gosh, you need to have the scale on. She's fantastic. I just
love her. I love her podcast. I spoke so highly of her. Did a little bit of research into what
she does. I'm involved with home birth at this time. The daughter that is going that was introduced
us is going to have her first baby and it will be a home birth. She was our home birth baby. We have
five kids and I think I mentioned it before. We had one, and this is this daughter at home. So
we are intimately involved with it. I have another daughter that had multiple home births, daughter,
long multiple home births. So why are we talking about home birth when we're a cancer clinic? Because
it's a natural way to live. It's a natural way to keep your children safe. To me, it's just in our
heart. This is how you need to raise your kids. I know it's not for everybody. We're not trying to
shame people that go to the hospital for birthing, but we do want to speak to this. So Caitlin,
your home birth mother, home birth educator, obviously experienced a 10-D of home births,
hosted creator of the Happy Home Birth Podcast. You have a lot of information and webinars,
your home birth myth busters. We have to chat a little bit about that. The top eight home birth
resources. Let's just jump into it. Caitlin, tell us a little bit more about yourself.
Oh, well, thank you so much for having me. This is such an honor and a privilege to be here.
I, my name is Caitlin Fusco. Like you said, and the way this all started for me, it's kind of an
odd story. I feel like most of these things are. My mother had all of her children via C section.
And so growing up, my idea of birth, my thought was, oh, well, my mom had C sections. She wasn't able,
I'm using air quotes for those who are listening. She wasn't able to give birth vaginally. So I won't
be able to as well. My body just isn't designed to work that way. So growing up, that's what I
thought. I'd be a C section mom. And, you know, there are certainly times when that's very
thank goodness we have that. But the idea that children are growing up thinking that they're not
even capable of trying to attempt natural childbirth is, is pretty sad. And it was just by chance,
once I graduated college, I had a mentor in my field who told me that she had given birth to her
baby in a tub outside of the hospital. And my mind was just blown. I had never heard of anybody
giving birth in a tub. Is that safe? Is that sanitary? And you can give birth outside of the hospital.
What? The concept was just so new to me, which is funny when we think about the fact that
home birth is as old as humanity, you know. So that happened, like that chance happening,
that chance moment of learning that there was another option just shattered my world in the best way.
And I am a researcher at heart. So I went home and just started finding all the information
that I could about giving birth outside of the hospital. Home birth honestly wasn't even on the
table at that point. It was, I was looking at this birth center. And I was years off from having
children. But I already was thinking, wait, people give birth without even an epidural?
That seems kind of hard. I think I want to do that. Like, you know, it just became this interesting,
like, wow, people can do that. Well, I want to be one of those people. So that was put on the back
burner as I continued on during in my field that I had trained for in college. And at that time,
I'd soon after I graduated, I realized this is not really what I want to be doing forever. So I knew
that I was very interested in in holistic health. I decided to do a health coaching certification.
During that certification, I was asked to kind of find a niche. Who am I going to focus on?
Who am I going to be serving? And I thought, well, wouldn't it be amazing to work with pregnant
mothers and really help them focus in on nutrition so that the next generation is impacted as well.
And so these mothers are learning techniques. They'll pass these on to their kids. I then thought
who would be interested in this information? And thought, well, maybe midwives. Maybe midwives'
clients would be interested. So I went to the government, the DHEC website for my state and found
a list of midwives and just started calling them one by one to see if they'd be interested. And
low and behold, the first midwife who answered her phone turned out to be the midwife that I would work
with and who would be my midwife when I had my children. And once I asked her if she'd be interested,
she said she'd love to meet. And once I met her and found out what it was that she did,
I was like, oh, this is what I need to be involved in. This is incredible. This concept of home birth,
giving birth in your own home, you're not being touched and poked and prodded by these other people.
It was just such an incredible concept to me. And once I attended my first home birth, there was
absolutely no turning back. You once you see something that powerful, yet intimate and vulnerable
and just a woman doing this, you know, nobody's touching her. She doesn't need any help. She's
able to bring forth life. I mean, it was just astounding. And it's forever ingrained in my mind.
And at that point, I was hooked. So I became an apprentice to this midwife. And I worked with her
until I got pregnant myself and continued on apprenticing. That was really neat to be both the
apprentice and the client and kind of learned from both sides. I had my first baby at home. I continued
to work with this midwife until she hit toddlerhood. And my midwife moved away. And at that point,
I thought, well, I'm going to have to find another midwife to work with. This is going to be hard. My
daughter really probably needs me at home right now. So that's when I came home, decided to quit
attending births for the time being. And then realized there really aren't any resources for home
birth mothers. And so that's when I started creating resources for these mothers started with the
Happy Home Birth podcast. And that which is essentially just mother sharing birth stories telling how
they were successful. And a lot of times, you know, that's what we need to hear. We need to hear
the actual stories of how things unfold, what circumstances came up that were unexpected and how
were those dealt with. Just the ins and outs of what birth can look like and how there's quite
a spectrum of what normal is. So we started there. And then I became pregnant with my second daughter.
And thought that even though my first birth was wonderful, there were some things that I didn't
even realize were possible. Just based off of interviewing other women, I thought, wow, I really
maybe could be more present during this experience. So I created some techniques for myself to use
during my second birth. And I ended up having a shockingly peaceful and present
birthing experience. And I thought, well, if I can do that, I think that other moms can certainly do
that. So that's when I created Happy Home Birth Academy, which is a comprehensive childbirth
education program focusing specifically on home birth. Because most childbirth education programs,
even those that, you know, are pro unmedicated birth are still really geared towards the hospital,
not very not as helpful as they could be for moms choosing to give birth at home. So that's where we
are today. And that's how I got here. Well, that's a great story. Some of the things I want to
touch on that you said that make me sad because we see the same thing. We have been so reeducated in
this country towards the practice of hospitalized medicine and that the doctor knows best. And you
can't know anything. Current state of affairs, you're being ridiculed if you do any research on your
own to try to take care of yourself and made fun of and de-platformed. So it's a sad state of
affairs. We see it all the time with our cancer patients, people here that they have the C word.
And boy, they're just going to go right down the standard protocol pathway without really
investigating other things. It's it's very similar with any health experience, whether a person's
pregnant, like you said, your friend told you about a water birth and you're like, oh my gosh,
what is that? You know, that is that is that even sanitary. How little we know it's really it
makes you kind of sad when you when you when you look back at yourself and go, oh my gosh, how
indoctrinated. How was I? How in the dark have I been? You know, you think of what when we had our
our fourth child, the one that has been followed with your podcast, when we had her at home,
it was just me and my sister who were helping my wife, of course, my wife did all the work. But
um, we were like load sharks. I mean, having home births was was not a cool thing at all. Back then,
there was zero support. I think I went off a little blue book, the emergency child birth book that I
that I had. That's the only resource. This was before the internet. And that was the only resource
to have a resource like you have created for women to be able to be supported when
their family and friends maybe are less supportive than they than they could be partly due to
their ignorance. Part of they just don't know is just a blessing. It's just a it's just a huge blessing
for people to have that information. Well, I appreciate that. So what are some what are some
main things that if you, you know, talk about your myth busters, um, because I think I love that
term of your little webinar series that people can subscribe to because just what we're talking about.
There's just so many so so much misinformation out there about everything, but certainly about
home births. What are some of your myth busters that the biggest things that people would
communicate to you or that you have followed over the years doing this? Oh yeah, that's there are a
few that just get asked over and over. I feel like I should just make a form email to be able to send
to people with some of these because it's it's just like you said, the indoctrination is just so strong
and you don't really realize it until you somehow rise above it. Um, but one of the things that I
have heard over and over again is, well, I can't have a home birth right now because this is my first
baby. So I'm going to have this baby in the hospital. And then if it goes well, I'll come home
up, you know, for the second one. So, and with that, you know, my thought is as well, you don't have
to have a bad experience to allow yourself to have a good experience. And I say that based on
countless, I mean, the hundreds of interviews that I've conducted pretty much everyone. There are
some exceptions, but they usually turn to home birth with their second, third, fourth child because
they've been burned so much in the hospital because they've been abused or manipulated. And the doctor
said, oh, sure, we'll support you. And we'll let you give birth naturally. And then they say, oh,
actually, you know, the baby's in danger. And now you have to have betosan. And this cascade of
intervention comes on after that. So usually the baby's in danger because you're giving birth in the
wrong position in the hospital. And then they push on a drug on you and say things like, oh, good
thing you were here. This would have been a catastrophe if you were at home. Just the lies that are
propagated are just mind boggling. It's sick. It's so it's so wrong to think. I mean, you know,
it starts well before the mother is even in labor. If they let her get to labor, that's the problem is,
you know, at what, 35 weeks, they're already starting to do cervical checks. What's the point?
What does that have to do with anything? And then with all of the ultrasounds, oh, we've got to check
the baby. Well, there's not a very much fluid. And this baby looks to be huge. I mean, ultrasound,
number one, they weren't even made for what they're being used for. So the fact that they're using this
to check on babies, there can be great, you know, I'm sure that many things are found and that's
wonderful. But a lot of times, a lot of problems arise from these constant scans because they're going
to pick up something. And the chances of it being accurate are pretty small. They say there's a two
pound or more dip, like estimate difference for an ultrasound. So these doctors are saying, oh,
your baby, your baby's huge. Your baby's huge. You're not going to be able to birth this baby. You're
going to have to have a C section. And it turns out it's a seven pound baby. Like it's just their
fear tactics upon fear tactics upon fear tactics to make the mother and the family feel like they
need the doctor to save them when they don't realize that you hold all of the power. You are the
one that's in control. Don't let these people make you think otherwise. And unfortunately, like you
said, our society is just set up at this point to where we think that if a doctor says it, then it's
as good as gold. It's yet these doctors have not been trained in physiological childbirth. So
what are we doing? Why are we listening to this? It's frustrated. I'm sure you get frustrated all
the time over this. And you just shake your head and you just got to move on and take care of the
next person that wants to really do things right. Right. And just I mean, continuing to put the
information out there. I am seeing, especially with the state of the world right now, there are more
people that were kind of on the fence about giving birth at home are jumping to the home birth side
because they're seeing what's going on in these hospitals right now. And a lot of trust is starting
to waver. And I mean, I think that that's a good thing for us to have happening. Another one that
really comes to mind is the idea of home birth not being safe. You know, I can't have a home birth.
It's not even safe. And this one, I think, is there, there are two, I think, that are just the
biggest underlying issues. And this is one of them is this concern for safety. And what I feel
like is missing, the missing information is that midwives, if you choose to use a midwife,
they are trained medical professionals. They don't just show up to your house barefoot. And I mean,
some, you know, if you want to choose one that's not a medical professional, that's totally fine.
And they probably have some great tricks too. But if you're choosing, you know, a certified midwife,
a licensed midwife, they've been trained in life-saving techniques. So some of the biggest
issues that arise during birth for the mother would be a hemorrhage postpartum. Midwives carry
medication and herbs for that. So usually if there is a little bit more bleeding than one would
want, they're going to start with herbs and head it off. If they need more, well, then they've got
that. They have it with them. So there's not this concern of, oh, something goes wrong, and then we
all die. That's not how it works. And then there can be shoulder dissociation is another, another issue
that people really, really worry about. And these things that are occurring, they are true emergencies,
but they happen whether you're at home or in the hospital. So with a shoulder dissociation,
the benefit of not being at the hospital is when you're at the hospital, number one, if your baby
doesn't come out in one contraction, they consider that a shoulder dissociation, which is just physiological,
like that's physiologically incorrect. There is oftentimes a break between once the head is born
and once the body is born. But if it doesn't come out in one, they're going to start trying to
yank the baby out, and they call it a shoulder dissociation. When you're at home, midwives know that
this is common. And when there is a true shoulder dissociation, you have, you're not attached to anything,
you're not hooked up to anything. You're not being forced to lay on your back. You can get up and move
positions, switch your body around, and the baby comes out. I mean, that is what happens.
So that's another really big concern. And then the third one that people really worry about is,
well, what if the baby's not breathing? And that happens, babies need stimulation. It's usually one
out of every 10 babies needs some amount of stimulation, but usually that's a flick of the foot,
or rubbing the baby, or one or two little breaths. The difference is when you're in the hospital,
they immediately, what's the first thing they do is they cut the cord. Your baby is born,
cord is cut. Your baby is still receiving oxygen through the placenta, through the blood supply,
until the placenta is done pulsating or until the cord is cut. So the safest thing for your baby
is to remain attached to the placenta so that it has those few moments, even minutes to come around.
That's perfectly normal. And when we're in the hospital, you see, once again,
everything counter to what makes physiological sense is being done for the sake of experience
of the hospital. Oh, this will make it faster so the doctor could get out of the room and get
out to the next thing. So the nurses can sweep the baby away to the nursery. You can just go on and on
and just do the absolute inhumane treatment of childbirth in the hospital. Sorry, I get
passionate about this because it's just whole thing. Yeah, it is. And I mean, it's everything.
You know, it makes you wonder because every single thing that is done is counter to bonding.
It's it's counter to the mother and child having those moments together with with the
pheromones where they are both covered in all of the hormones of birth. And those necessary imprinting
moments are just stripped away from everybody at the hospital. That's very concerning that we're growing
up in these generations where the bond has been at least at the very least, we can say it's been
manipulated. Yeah, exactly. So those are some of your biggest myths that you have to overcome.
Would you talk about your checklist of your AAU to give your top five? We don't
give away all your secrets here. Yeah, sure. What are some of the other things that a person who's
like considering this might want might encounter might want to know about?
So my top eight resources that I've created, it's actually links to different podcast episodes that
I've done or that others have done that talk about some of the most important aspects of this journey.
And one of the things that I really and it has become one of my goals for mothers to understand
is this relationship to what birth really is, what it has been all along. And that's a right of
passage. And when we look at, you know, traditional societies, there was so much build up to birth.
You know, usually couples that were about to conceive, they were given special diets,
highly nutrient dense diets. They there was such a to-do made about giving birth.
And now, I mean, what the water down version of that is a baby shower. I mean, that's really
basically, you know, here there are these huge ritualistic experiences and now we have a baby
shower. Like it's just, it's kind of interesting how that has watered down. But what happens is,
is when we don't realize that this is just a massive transformational experience where you are going
from mother from maiden to motherhood for the first or 15th time. I don't care every single time.
This is a huge transformative moment. When we don't realize that as we're preparing,
we get to the moment and don't know what to do. And so when we prepare knowing, hey,
there's a huge transition coming up. This is transformational. It's wonderful. And expressing
it as something good and positive and life changing. When we do it that way, there's excitement.
And there's a realization that, oh, I'm in control of this and I have responsibility versus asking
for others to take this from us. No, we want to experience it. So that would be my first thing,
would be recognizing that this is a right of passage. And it's a wonderful thing. And then the
second aspect would be this idea of responsibility. And kind of like what we've alluded to a number of
times is, we have so often, we're so used to and so conditioned to give away our responsibility.
Oh, doctor, take care of me. You know, what is wrong with me? Tell me what is wrong with me
and I will do whatever you say versus I am, I know my health better than anybody else.
I know my body better than anybody else. I am in control and I am responsible for my health
and for the situation. It's the exact same with birth. You are as the mother. You are the responsible
party, whether you want to be or not, whether that feels like a burden or not. I mean, it's reality.
When you become pregnant and you're growing a new life, you are the one that is responsible.
And it can feel scary or we can step into this fact and hold it for all that it's
worth and and milk it for all that it's worth really enjoy every aspect of it and know that we
are going to take care of our child better than anybody else, any single person else.
This this opportunity, this birth, this labor, all of it, it means more to us than it does to
anybody else. So we can feel confident in the decisions that we're going to make. We don't have to
give up our responsibilities to a doctor who says that, you know, your baby is too big and your
pelvis is too small. So really understanding that is I feel like it's critical. Well, I love those two
points because they equate so much to our practice with cancer as well. If you don't embrace your
cancer in the way that this is this can be a good thing. There's things to learn about this. Let's
let's embrace this and deal with the fear side because just like you were talking about, women are
fearful and then they end up giving responsibility over to somebody else. It's in them holding onto
that responsibility and not be this kind of like a victim in this whole situation. Your body makes
different chemicals. Your adrenals and your pituitary make different chemicals when you're stuck in
that fear state. You stay in this sympathetic tone environment. Things are not going to work. Your
immune system is not going to work as well, dealing with the disease. And you talk about pelvic
relaxation. If you're in a more of a parasympathetic tone, a home environment, comfort, at ease,
familiarity, your parasympathetic nervous system is going to relax those those ligaments and the
toe of those ligaments. So it just it compliments so much. And then getting rid of that
turning over responsibility to somebody else. And part of it is again, something that we as
Americans have been conditioned to do. Oh, they're the experts. Let's just give it to them.
And we grew up in the last several generations of not wanting to take responsibility for our
own actions as well. Well, I don't want to have to learn all that. I don't want to have to do all
that. And it's a shame because there's consequences to be paid if you live your life that way.
In all sorts of things. What is the last piece of advice you could give our listeners?
So one of the things and actually as as I was listening to you say that I was just thinking about
you know, with the with the responsibility and just shirking that responsibility how it has been
kind of programmed into us. When we step to the other side of that, there are just so many
benefits. And also recognizing that your outcomes may not be perfect. If you give birth at home,
there's no guarantee that things are going to go well for you. If you give birth in the hospital,
there's no guarantee that things are going to go well for you. That is something that like you said.
And I think it's why we're so willing to give responsibility because we think someone else is going
to come and save us. You know, this doctor is going to come save me from my illness. This doctor is
going to come save me from my labor. That that's not how it works. You know, if we can accept the
responsibility and accept the fact that we don't necessarily have control over our outcomes,
we just have control over how we prepare. Then we can kind of let go of the rest. And I I always think
about control versus surrender. What can I control? Well, I can control how I prepare. I can eat in a
way that is nutrient dense and helping my body and my baby. I can educate myself on every aspect of
pregnancy, of labor, of childbirth. I can select a team around me that is going to support me
and that I trust and who knows that I am the leader of the team. I can do all of these things.
And then the specific outcomes, typically because of all that preparation, they are going to go well.
That's, you know, that when you prepare so much is is put in your favor. However, like I said,
I mean, we can't we don't know we don't know exactly what's going to happen just like we don't know
in the hospital. So understanding that there is a balance of control versus surrender and learning
to be okay with it because that's just the way that life is. You know, I can't control what happens to
me when I get in my car. I can do things to prepare. I can wear my seatbelt. I can drive according to
the traffic laws. I don't know what else is going to have. I can't, I can't, you know, say that this
is a specific outcome that's going to happen. And I mean, that's it's a hard fact what that is
the fact of life. So that's that's a side. But the other thing that I wanted to talk about here at
the end is why is why can we say that birth is safer at home? What are the things that makes it
safer? So I have five different things that I wanted to share about that. And number one, like I said,
with midwives, they're trained. They are they are medical professionals, but we are safer with
midwives because they're not trained in surgery. And whereas obese, their main training is surgery.
And that's wonderful for when they have to provide surgery. But are they going to see everything as
a pathology that requires surgery? I don't know if your eyes are trained to see something then
that might be what you're seeing. So there's not going to be any positive for a midwife to add
additional interventions. Whereas with a hospital system, they're going to be making more money
if they add different interventions. And it's easier for them. So yeah, exactly. So number two would be
that midwives know the mother and baby that they know them individually. So they know their benchmarks
for normal. Whereas when we're in a hospital system and we're kind of just like on the conveyor belt
of treatment, you might not see the same doctor ever, you know, each prenatal appointment. You may see
a different doctor. I know that our local hospital system has doctor groups of like 17. So you're not going
to know all of those doctors, best case scenario you've met the doctor once in that situation that's
going to be helping you deliver life into the world. So they don't know you. They don't know your baby.
They don't know what's normal for you. Whereas if you're working with a midwife that you see consistently,
she knows exactly what your blood pressure normally is. She knows exactly where your baby
normally likes to hang out. All of these things that are so important and critical to understanding the
story that's being told during labor. So that provides a huge level of safety because a midwife can
know, oh, this isn't normal for this baby to have these heart tones or this isn't normal for this
mother to have this blood pressure reading. These things are really important and doctors aren't going
to be able to pick up on that. Number three, physiological labor requires said prefers on this paper
that I wrote down, but it requires dark and quiet known places for the correct hormonal release.
So you think about one example I think it's in one of Dr. Bradley's books is your cat. Your cat
doesn't just walk out in the middle of lunch hour and sprawl out and have her kittens in front of
everybody. That's not how physiological hormones work. So your cat will go off to a closet or under
the house somewhere dark usually at night to give birth to these kittens away from everybody else because
that's how the hormones flow the best. So when we take birth oftentimes mom will start laboring at home
and then what do they do? They leave their house. That's intervention number one is just leaving your
safe home where you were comfortably laboring. They go to a hospital where they know practically nobody
where there are fluorescent lights everywhere where there are machines that they're hooked up to.
Nurses coming in and out asking for different things and having you sign admission paperwork and
usually sign like okay a C section when you like first arrive which is like why? But so all of these
things are happening do we think that that's positive for hormone release? No that's the opposite of
what your body needs. When you're trying to relax everything that's going on around you is making
you tighten and close up. So yeah so home is where we are used to being vulnerable. It's where we are
used to being surrounded by people that we love and intimacy there's with an allowance for darkness
or low lighting you know this place. So there's safety there. And then let's see when number four
would be when hormones are less active so when we're going to the hospital would be the example then
or excuse me when we're staying home when hormones are more active there is less of a chance of
issues arising because we have all of these different hormonal feedback loops that are going on during
labor. When you put something in that feedback loop like when you when you halt it then there is so
much more chance for stall labor or all of these different things to happen whereas if you just don't touch
it just don't touch anything let the hormones go on their own there's far less opportunity for
mishap to arise. And then number five I think this is really huge and people are not talking about
it enough but you kind of alluded to it when you said well hospitals are a great place to go to die
but we have our own microbiome in our house we have our own germs we have our own bacteria everything
around us we are used to it we know these the bacteria in our house we know this microbiome and one
thing that is interesting is people used to think that the amniotic sac was sterile there's nothing
in it just sterile fluid that's I mean that doesn't even make sense anyway but it's not it's got
all of our bacteria in it so bacteria do you think is going to be in there it's going to be the same
bacteria that we're exposed to consistently in our environment so our baby is used to this bacteria
our baby is used to this microbiome you're telling me that it makes more sense to take them to a hospital
have them exposed to this totally new microbiome that includes like crazy strains of staff
and strep versus keeping them at home in the microbiome that they were literally conceived
into and grown into it's certainly something to consider oh yeah and that that is huge we could have
a couple hour seminar just on your microbiome right right okay you are a wealth of knowledge
what a blessing um we're gonna have all your information up on this video um for people to go to
and I understand most people at our listening to our podcast are dealing with cancer but they have
family members that would maybe like to start out life the right way and do things the correct way
last thing I want to ask you is a question that we get from patients as well when when people are
choosing a natural way an alternative sadly you could say it is alternative to standards of care
when they're choosing a natural way there's pushback that they get from family members
what do you tell your clients to do about that pushback well that is a great question and I
certainly understand how that would be common on your end as well um one thing I've I've kind of given
two concepts about this you have two choices really it's okay do these do these family members
and and usually of course they want they they have your best interest at heart they care about you
they're worried about the choices that you're making they're just misguided so is there a chance
that by you providing education they are going to come around and accept what you are saying
if so then by all means provide them with the education kindly talk to them and say look this is
what we're deciding this is why we've chosen it here's some research to back it up if you'd like and
and that's great if however you know that whatever you say is not going to make a difference
hard as it may be sometimes the best thing is not to say anything at all and just close it for
discussion because we don't want constant negative feedback from what we're doing if in your mind you
know that home birth is the correct option for you or if in your mind you know that you do not want to
go to the hospital for chemo if you know this then you have to stand strong in what you believe
and maybe it means we don't talk about it with these other people we can we can kindly close that
door so I've told my clients before you can say like oh thank you so much this is what we've decided to
do and and it's not up for discussion because this is the choice that we're making but it is about
it's kind of like what we've been talking about it is about coming to terms with the fact that
you are in charge of your own body and and you got to just accept that responsibility sometimes
it's not fun to do that but sometimes I mean but that is that's your choice yeah that's the healthiest
way to do it well thank you so much thank you so much again we just love having you and I'm so glad my
daughter you know just introduced us and and now I can see why she loves your podcasts so oh thank you
so much dr. Connor so it was such a joy to be here we're going to keep spreading the word
and we'll have you let again sounds great thank you bye bye now